you ever watched the goonies when they
was chasing that treasure that's what
they was looking for
ladies and gentlemen this is hancho's
treasure chest
what's up gq this quavo honcho and these
are my 10 essentials
[Music]
tons of jury tons of diamonds tons of
ice
bust down watches
the three amigo game
some championship rings lots of charms
tons of bracelets emerald diamonds pave
honeycomb settings we got this one
playing but it's like a half a kilo
cuban big carrots
not pointers like carrot carrot chains
kind of like this
tennis chains okay serena hey venus i
got it all in the treasure chest and i
got to have it i got to have my jewelry
never know when you're trying to shine
[Music]
i can't go nowhere without my louis v
headphones these was one of the first
pair sent to me from kevin durant and
then when my boy virgil got into louie
this this was like one of the first
things that they was doing so rp the
virgin and i can't go nowhere without my
lv earpods indeed
[Music]
these are
my handy dandy scissors and these is for
cutting good jungle leaves we roll up a
good joint and go to the moon
i don't like breaking down with my hands
because it makes your fingernails dirty
so i like to
cut and roll
[Music]
these are my houses aka my watches i
feel like they real estate and i got to
have them with me and i can't go nowhere
without a few plain james on me they
kind of like real estate these are like
little mini houses that just go up in
value i don't buy bus downs no more
because it don't make any sense it's
kind of like taking a lambo and just
taking the roof off it and just
depreciating your car so i got a good
relationship with the with the people
that's you know i'm saying that sell
these watches which is ap shout out to
ap shout out to greg over there ap and i
just go in there and just get them out
the store just like i'm buying shoes a
lot of people can't do that this one is
probably about a million dollars right
now
with the ruby before
like two something and it's almost over
guarantees over half of me i just got
this one
and i left my rainbow at the house my
rainbow is almost 7 700 so this is what
i got to have on the road you know a
couple of planes make sure they playing
make sure they real deal take the ice
out unless it's fat they're diamonds
like these these are factory diamonds
did by paddock itself
[Music]
see as you can see when i'm traveling i
make anything a case so this is a boy's
headphones case that i store my glasses
in because my glasses taste too big to
go on my my my stuff so
i got my product frames two pair of
products
these are
yeah balenciaga these cartier's these
probably 28k with the diamonds in them
my million dollar frames right here
these the louis v anything with louis v
we're gonna be rp diversion
sunglasses i feel like all the time all
the time all the time i'm always losing
something that's the part of the game
you're gonna lose you're gonna lose some
you're gonna break some somebody's gonna
steal one like you cannot leave you
can't leave these in the hotel at all
they gonna go these is crazy right now
i'm getting some new ones made
with all the diamonds around them again
cause i lost them i miss my glasses
[Music]
i would turn the car around i would turn
the plane around if i forget my teeth
pardon me ladies and gentlemen
just like that we live i got to have my
grill shout out to johnny dang these are
new these are brand new with the purple
pink stones in them top of the line 101
shout out to johnny and shout out to
houston i love you all today this is
one of one once again i did it again
some call it activist some call it pink
panther something called a raindrop so
i'm calling you know what i'm saying
purple rain some call it church windows
purple church windows the house of the
lord yes ma'am and i just call them pink
glaciers
that's what i call them and that's what
they is and i love them i don't wear
them all the time because i got to make
sure the pink and the purple and stuff
match you know when you eat like a
burger sometimes like the bone gets in
like the meat i thought it was a bone
but it was a stone i thought it was a
bone and it was a stone i was wrong
diamond pop that almost swallowed sixty
thousand you heard drake it happens
[Music]
i'm nowhere
lacking i'm never alone and i always
have to have five
so
we got to keep five
whether it's a lighter or five you just
gotta have it
[Music]
i got to have something to travel with
got to put my cases and stuff in so
we're going to go yard we're changing up
the bags we put the louise away we put
the louise up right now and um what's in
the bag is
very
interesting you got to keep it on you
never know when you want to buy
something or you want to do like
fun things
or if you want to buy like a car
or just buy some jury
you know that's what you do
you got to keep some of it on you
oh in my wallet
that's it
my id and my vegas playing card
that's all
what's happening y'all that's it that's
my tent essentials thank y'all for
checking out my essentials hopefully you
can take notes and put some of those
essentials in your essentials
hunch up we gone